okay let's talk a little bit about tara
reid
tara reed is the woman who accused joe
biden of sexual assault
now uh i'm not here to evaluate her
claims
to play tit for tat to debunk things i'm
getting a lot of emails from people
saying david i need you to go through
the evidence did she do it or didn't she
did did she uh do it meaning did she
file the complaint or didn't she file
the complaint
did biden do it or did he not do it i'm
not able to do that
and nor do i think it's the appropriate
thing to do what i am here to tell you
is
from a political standpoint in terms of
figuring out what you're going to do in
november if you were someone who is
debating what to do in november on the
basis of the tara reid situation
there is never going to be a conclusive
investigation that tells us what
happened
okay we you all need to understand this
and you're going to have to figure out
what to do in november
without a conclusion from an
investigation
and the reason that it's not going to
happen is that it essentially cannot
happen given what we know
i'm going to explain what i mean in a
moment the reason this is important
is that a lot of people who don't like
biden and don't like trump
are now taking advantage of the tara
reid story
to essentially not have to make a
decision about
whether voting for biden is better than
voting for trump
people who clearly are on biden's side
on the
issues or closer to biden's side than
trump's on the issues
are insisting that until they know the
truth about what happened in the 1990s
until it's really investigated they
can't decide
it's time to skip to the end any
investigation that takes place
based on what's been made what
allegations have been made so far
would not tell you whether this did or
did not happen it wouldn't
this is not just about he said she
said although it it is this is not about
believe women or don't as i've said
before
making allegations is very serious it
exposes the victim to harassment and
shame
and the whole thing it must be taken
seriously when a victim
makes an allegation this is simply about
all that i'm talking about now
is that there could not possibly be
based on everything we know right now
a conclusive investigation there's a
bigger topic as well which is
can someone prove they did not commit a
sexual assault when the allegations
themselves are like the ones we have
here
there's only a very narrow way that you
could prove you did not commit a sexual
assault and that would be
like imagine that tara reid filed a
complaint on a specific day
and we saw oh the allegation is that
this supposedly took place on this day
and then biden's travel schedule
from that time shows he was out of the
country
okay maybe in that narrow scenario you
could conclude he didn't do it
but beyond that you can't really prove
you didn't commit sexual assault and in
this particular case
we can't even find the complaint biden
said release certain records but he
hasn't said release others
tara reid doesn't have a copy of the
complaint she previously said the
complaint was for sexual assault now she
says the complaint she did file
doesn't mention sexual assault but it
describes sexual harassment
but there's no copy of the complaint so
what i am telling you is
not that she's telling the truth or that
she's lying we should take her
allegations seriously
but there is not a complaint to
investigate joe biden cannot prove his
innocence nor is there any way to
confirm tara reid's allegations
there couldn't be a conclusive
investigation now what about this idea
that's floating around that
she was fired because of the complaint
that she filed
it's such a mess at this point that no
investigation could conclude
anything she says she was fired for
filing the complaint we can't find
there's a negative performance review on
file whose timing can be used to call
this into question well
what if you go and talk to witnesses
well tara reed says she approached
three biden aides about this back in the
90s all three of those people told the
new york times they don't know anything
about it could they have forgotten
sure could they be lying sure but the
point is
it would be like the kavanaugh
investigation where it is impossible to
conclude
this happened or this didn't happen um
given that there is no way that an
investigation would ever tell us
biden did it or biden didn't do it the
message is you're going to have to
decide whether you prefer trump or biden
to be president
i think there are lots of people who
would love a way out of voting for joe
biden
and would see biden did it as a bailout
that they need to feel okay
about taking an action that helps
re-elect donald trump
listen the dnc screwed itself they
selected a sexual assaulter
they lost my vote but that investigation
is not going to happen
and you're going to have to decide on
the issues now does any of this clear
abide and of course not there
there's almost no way biden could be
cleared
again if it was determined that on the
day tara reid claims this happened biden
was in china that might clear him but
you'd still have people say oh i'm sure
tara reid just doesn't remember the
right date if the investigation
determined as almost every single one of
these do
that it cannot find evidence to confirm
tara reid's story nor can it find
evidence to disprove
tara reid's story people will read that
as whatever they want either it happened
but there's not enough evidence maybe
because the evidence was
suppressed people will come up with that
or people will say
see i told you there's no evidence that
this thing happened
it doesn't matter in the end because you
are going to need to decide
given that there will never be such a
conclusion you will need to decide
what is better for the country in
november i'm not going to evangelize my
point of view
you all know the calculation i've made
you are going to have to make the same
calculation without the benefit
of a conclusive investigation which
there will never be there may be an
investigation
there is no way given what we know that
it would be conclusive and give you the
answer many of you are waiting for
if you disagree let me know i'm on
twitter at deepakman
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video